all right
uh it's seven o'clock
ladies and gentlemen so i think we all
should get started
good evening and welcome
councillors
ladies and gentlemen
to the joint transportation board
uh
i'll go through the usual fire procedure
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices by via the stairs
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the lifts
assembly in hawley square on the green
and officers
we should be you i guess
we'll assist and advise when it's deemed
safe to return to the chamber could
everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones switch to silent
and that they're not to use to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting's in progress
i must advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in public
areas
which there are none may have their
image captured
um
i'm assuming that nobody here is going
to be filming tonight
okay and we'll go on
straight on to
the agenda does any member wish to speak
under 21
no
i thought you remember
pardon oh sorry i am a member
so we go straight on to agenda item one
are there any apologies for absence
um
can i just have a point of information
do you have any apologies from any of
the officers that
we expect to be at these meetings
um
i know that uh officers are not coming
uh obviously charles is here in place of
james tonight and as far as i know
paul valek is not coming
i have no idea if any other officers are
coming i have had no apologies but i as
you know
they have been informed from kcc that
they are not obliged to come
to
evening meetings
i can't speak for tdc officers but um
in that case
can we
note
our disapproval of the fact that we are
not having any kent county council
officers
present because what's the point of
having a joint transport board if the
people who
should be listening to us aren't present
um i think it's a very valid point
mr lewis and um uh
i know that others around the room agree
with that um i think it's
quite noticeable now that uh
and you'll forgive me if i say that i
belong to the elon musk view
that if you don't turn up on a monday
we'll assume you've resigned
and you can go and work for somebody
else and pretend to be working from home
um is what he is apparently supposed to
have said i believe that officers should
be here
i know it's inconvenient to come in the
evening but i think it's part and parcel
of the job at a certain level
so i'm afraid i tend to agree with you
but councillor scoby more than that
when paul valik was here you're include
straight answers quickly to questions
the fact he's not here you can't even
get those straight quick answers
counselor
we're here to represent ramsgate i am
anyway
and the fact that we've got no kcc
officers
i've got a whole raft of issues
there they are ram's getting specs
there's no point me sitting here because
there's no officers to talk to so
therefore i should pack up and go home
it's absolutely disgraceful that we give
up our time an excuse and excuse me
which i've been at kcc telling them
since june 21 they can't come out
because they're cold what do we do every
night anyway there's no point me sitting
there because
kcc
i've spoken to david brazier
these people on different planets
thank you mr shark i would advise you
that as a member of kcc you are able at
any point to go to
paul vallec during the day or with your
with your questions can i just come back
however i would like to just say that if
you'd like to leave anything i'm quite
happy to uh make that possible for me
yeah thank you and i think i think it's
a very valid point that's um i think
we're all pretty disappointed i think it
should be minuted that the
committee is very disappointed that
um councillors from both tdc and kcc
have taken the time to turn up
and those that are
paid to fulfill
their job
have not
wanted to do so
i'll come back we're happy with that
yeah can i come back to that i've worked
with paul ryan i'm not picking on the
person because i'm i'm a people person
i've been to that side to casey sandwich
more times than i should do
they look at me if i scrape something
off their shoe this is a amy that was
another
part of the kcc everybody's fluffing
around making excuses why officers are
not there
and i said
any of you people ever heard of time and
motion
they just look at me
he should be here he was here he's out
he's out and about well if he's not here
it's never here
anyway i apologize to everybody but i do
try to represent ramsgate near the call
newington and all at the moment i'm
hitting a brick wall
thank you council
uh we will note your comments
um
i nevertheless do feel that we should
continue because
uh there are some issues here
sorry he's a ttc he's a tdc yes but
um we are here to discuss certain issues
and i think that we do have to do that
tonight
derek you wanted to say something yeah i
would just like to say in defense of
paul valak he's only doing what he's
told to do
absolutely yeah last night i had a
former kcc councillor reported a tree
broke tree falling in the road near
esmond drive at manston
he was in margate in half an hour he was
up with his train short job sorted yep
the first class operator you're quite
right the argument is not with the
officers in this particular case it is
really with with the um
the kcc
uh cabinet member who has decided that
that should be the case
and i think it's um it's right that we
note our comments and send them to the
cabinet member they could praise you
who is
has said quite bluntly that that's his
decision
and that's what he stands by despite any
complaints from
fellow councillors
okay can we
come back
quickly yeah because i raised it in the
first instance yes right
um what about the general public haven't
they got a right to here it's all right
saying you can talk to paul phallic in
private
fine but
we're supposed to be a public
service i'll send you a copy of the
email i sent to david brazier which
includes i'm sure we're on the same page
of course um
i also said that this was the
opportunity for the public to hear
about
uh issues listening this is this is live
stream this is live stream they are
listening to this is the only
opportunity they have to listen and hear
their their voice heard because we are
supposed to represent them and uh i
quite agree with you and i do think it's
deplorable uh and um i want it noted
okay we move on um
agenda item
one you had apologies yeah we do have
counsellor leslie leslie game and
that's it
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
nope
so we'll go straight on to agenda item
three which is minutes of previous
meeting that's the meeting held on the
22nd of march 2022
has everybody received
no that was part of the agenda
and
are we happy to approve this in which
case i'd need a proposal
councillor phil just to propose
councillor scoby to second all members
agreed
thank you
agenda item 4
north down road cliftonville margate
casualty reduction measures
members will note that they have a
supplementary agenda that's been
made available with an updated report
which you've all
i believe received so we will have
nobody to present this at all
which is deplorable
however that does not stop us from
making comments
council lewis
yeah as i
represent part of north down road
i support the proposals
with the caveats
that
over the years north down road has been
subject to many alterations
and yet in the last
decade there's been multiple
serious injuries and a number
of uh i think one fatality
i firmly believe
in the in the same um speed kills
i don't think just
tinkering
as this proposal does
with the measures however
slightly improved they are to what is
happening at the moment
i think
i think
without doubt
the solution
and recent history proves it the way you
stop accidents and fatalities and
injuries is 20 miles an hour speed
limits if you look
at ethelstone road which
is adjacent to
north down road
four years ago we put in 20 miles an
hour speed limit
and there hasn't been one
accident reported similarly with margate
seafront
there's been no accidents reported since
20 miles now the residents want 20 miles
an hour the business people want 20
miles an hour
so i would like
i would like to say to
the officer could he pass or now
comments to david brazier but in the
absence of anybody from kcc
could the chair
uh
make a note if it's approved with the
other councillors obviously that we
support it
with the rider that the
that the long-term solution is 20 miles
an hour speed limit
i don't know if i've got i don't do i
have to move that as a motion
i was just going to say that um
counselor game actually also said that
she basically approved of this in
general
but also would have liked to have seen a
20 mile per hour speed limit there so
that's also somebody that represents
part of
of
margate so
um but i wanted you to know that at
least council yates
uh thank you jeff um
i would also like to uh support uh the
20 mile an hour um speed limit for
northland road um
i've also privy to a letter from the
north unroad business community where
eight businesses wrote to the margate
town deal board
and in effect are highlighting the the
issues of speeding and dangerous driving
um
on their road and
although i
again like council lewis i support the
measures i think a 20 mile an hour speed
limit would be uh the best solution all
around thanks in addition to these
measures
in addition yeah
councillor brown
yeah i've yeah i've brought it to your
attention and the vice and councillor
right we've got this situation where
we've got 10 parish town councils
on the island and we haven't got one for
margate which includes cliftonville dane
valley westbrook and garland
what
councillor wright said to me uh earlier
should those wall councillors raise a
highways improvement plan where things
like 20 mile an hour limit can be on the
wish list
i certainly think it's a way forward
until such times we do have a town
council in margaret
yeah
any other
listeners wishing to speak cancer scoby
thank you um
yes i i was pleased to see improvements
uh proposed in this uh
to make northam road a safer place but i
agree that uh a 20 mile per hour speed
limit across the whole length of it
because uh we're talking about accidents
probably mainly on the
the the business part of it but as a
governor at cliftonville school
we've had a crossing put in by holly
lane which has helped to slow some of
the traffic and reduced um
incidents there but
from
north down park
to cliftonville school is a long
straight road and
i know when i'm trying to pull out of my
road onto it uh it's a bit of a race
track at times so i think a wider 20
mile per hour speed limit would be
better i see the welsh governments are
talking about uh a blanket 20 mile hour
which uh
maybe kent could could do
thank you
be interesting on the m2
um
and make your journey to london if you
ever do it
an awful lot longer
councillor cornford yes i just wanted to
add um also 20 miles an hour is um the
solution with the traffic the levels
that we have now the speed that people
drive
and the fact that somewhere like croydon
the whole center is 20 miles an hour
yes
um it does have to have enforcement of
course
um
in order to be
in order to be active but our our uh
well we're only asked actually that this
report we're told that this report is
for information and we're only asked
actually to note the report but uh if
members agree i'm quite happy to draft a
letter to
um
the cabinet member for highways
and
the department as well including the
area manager with
the comments of the committee
which are that essentially we agree with
the
amendments as uh suggested he has
proposed here however we feel that a 20
mile per hour
uh limit on a broader
in a broader sense in a broader range
should be considered for this area
our members happy for us to do that yeah
yeah
thank you one second
um
i think we've all agreed it
it's a letter
yes
thank you very much
then we go on to agenda item 5 the
highways works program
again there is nobody to present this
but you have your report in front of you
at least some of you do
i don't at the moment
um
i have
i have it again okay agenda item five
then um do we have any comments on this
or would you want to go through this a
page at a time or a section at a time or
would you like to just pull your
comments out as we go
counselor
well it it's a matter of commenting more
than anything else because as you said
there is nobody here to answer questions
so it makes it a very one-sided
um
discussion thanks the only comment i'd
like to make is that um
the main dual carriageway between
birchington and saint nicholas is has a
speed limit on it
but there is a cycle path on each side
which was pretty in 1938 i believe
and it is absolutely appalling you can't
use it comfortably because it's got
almost what i would call the
old-fashioned thunder strips but words
where it's all joined it's very
overgrown and i think that in this day
and age that we really should be looking
to make sure these are maintained to a
high standard so that people can ride
safely between saint nicholas
and than it or from canterbury because i
i just think that we're missing a trick
here we have a we have a whole
side which is each side which can go
either way the only difficulty you have
with that is that there is no way to get
across safely from one side to the other
and that's the only issue you have with
that um so if you want to carry on going
to the footbridge and you're on the
left-hand side then that's the
difficulty because there's no foot
there's no footpath on the left-hand
side of the a-28 so i do
whatever it is and i do think that needs
to be addressed and looked at at some
stage but
obviously there's nobody here from kent
to talk to about that so it does make
life difficult and you know transport
for england are look at this sort of
thing and they are trying to make sure
that
there are cycle routes and footpaths and
i mean people could use that as a
footpath but you can't get onto that
side of the road
safely because there's no footpath to
get to it so i mean something's got to
be looked at in a logical way
and i just like to make that point thank
you chad thank you
um i think that's something that
counselors wright and crowe brown can
pick up
and take up to
uh with highways
um the cycle path has for the last 60
years never been maintained very well
unfortunately it has a history of that
do cancer fellows yeah just to add to
what david was saying i think the um the
hoo-ha that was
created recently about a cycle path
between margate and birchington going to
spend six million pounds on it you know
a few thousand pound filling a few
cracks in a few more removing a few
weeds i think
should easily be sorted by council of
white and council cobrand
thank you
that will be that will go up we
if we cannot talk to people here then we
will make sure that uh the messages go
up to
um to highways
did i saw a hand go up i think it was
can't see yet
thank you jim um
it was just
i've got a question specifically about a
casualty reduction measure on page 11 a
marine terrace margate installation of a
curved roundabout a junction with marine
gardens
um i'm still quite shocked that coming
out of my gate station you've got
thousands of people
and there's no actual zebra crossing
onto the sea front um so i'm wondering
if this isn't if this is specifically at
the roundabout
outside the train station or whether
this is around about by the clock tower
it's not clear
and whether
um
any zebra crossings could be looked at
because it seems astonishing that you've
got thousands of people coming and they
either have to cross a road with no
zebra crossings no traffic lights onto
all saints avenue across the road to
dream one side or to go on the seafront
side they have to cross
a road with no junctions
onto margate seafront um i don't know if
that can be looked up
i thought there was a crossing there
somewhere
sorry
council lewis are you
i thought you might want to comment on
that
um
any any other comments about these works
because there are quite a few pages of
them and uh um
i could run through them all but some
are completed and i'm assuming that will
only pick up on the ones that we have
any interest in
that are being programmed
nope
again this
this item is for
information only we're asked the members
are asked to note the report can we
agree that we're noting the report and
that
the
couple of issues that have been
mentioned will be brought up by kcc
councillors
okay
are we happy to do sir
thank you
agenda item six proposed waiting
restrictions
uh on various roads infante
again
there is nobody here to discuss but it's
fairly
uh
fairly plain sailing as far as these are
concerned do we have any comments on any
of these
they'd be silent
no nothing at all
um
nothing from those whose uh his
areas are covered here
in which case the recommendation is to
that we recommend that the restrictions
be installed as advertised so can i have
a proposal
councillor fellows
and secondary councillor crowbrow
all members agreed
thank you
agenda item seven
proposed 30 mile per hour speed limit
along nash road margate
um again we have
uh various comments
um
councillor lewis
um i should inform the committee
that
um within the month hopefully there's
consultation going out in the samson
area which includes nash road to make
all roads
apart from rams gate road and the m2
um 20 mile an hour speed limits so
if you pass this
at the same time of asking residents
whether they want a 20 mile an hour
speed limit in this road you're going to
be asking them whether they want a 30
mile an hour speed limit
so i would
i don't know which way forward
it would happen but the right hand
doesn't know that what the left hand's
doing so i would
i do not know the way forward but i just
thought you should be aware that
consultation is imminent on making that
road a 20 mile an hour speed limit
consultation of public by kent county
council hi casey
uh councillor heart first then
councillor right dave
my only comment to that is realistically
um it hasn't hate in part yet or the
consultation hasn't happened so
therefore we just go ahead with um
reducing the speed to 30. um and that's
all i can say if if that comes at a
later date i mean i don't think every
rodent in that can become a 20 mile an
hour range you'll just have a log jam
everywhere um it does work in some
places but not in every road until you'd
never get around um but i mean to be
fair if they haven't had a consultation
yet well that comes after after the
after the event and what we have is in
front of us we just deal with that now
council right thank you
mike
sorry
derek and myself are actually part of
that consultation which james ray is
is doing
derek
yep
we did have there was one meeting i was
unable to go but derek did go so he
could probably tell you more about it
yeah this this this is in a in a road
network uh
which is james is working on um we are
organized meeting with roger gale
and mp's approval will get more funding
from the department for transport uh
so rogers agreed with it along with
most of
all the parish town councils
he's got certain caveats so
uh brooks mb and one of them uh
when you say
i'm not quite sure how far this reaching
this consultation
this actually
um extends
because as far as i know nobody's
approached broadstairs so are we talking
only about a certain area or just
yeah what i was referring to is in a
road network which is just the inner
road yeah which is nash road shotton
dane road
brooks end hill manston road okay
and that's what you're referring to as
well no no
um this is
a suggestion by the samsung resident
association a few years ago
there's been
work done
and it's past its stages of the
engineering side of it
and now it's going out
uh within the next month of consultation
so there's something residents
association so that is only for that
area
that's just for the samsung board okay
including this road that's been
mentioned but this road extends to other
areas too
yeah so this is from
from coffin house corner yeah to west
yeah it's part
yeah so westwood western
yeah
okay
well at the moment the only one that we
have here as councilheart says i agree
is we have a proposed 30 mile per hour
speed limit on nash road and that's the
only one that we have to discuss at the
moment
um
are there any questions about this
council fellows
thank you um i think there's more issues
this road than reducing speed i think
obviously it's too narrow for it for its
usage at the moment
and um you know i think
why they're changing the speed limit
maybe you have to put a white line down
the middle so people can judge in the
road where there's actually i think a
lot of the issues there people think
they're driving cars much wider than
that gr and don't stick to the side of
the road where they actually drive
and that's where a lot of accidents
occur so i think a white line down the
middle would help people to
stay to their side of the road
a lot of collisions where they're
clipping each other head-on so i think
why they're doing these sort of changes
maybe a white line can be added as well
um
yeah there have been various comments
about this um i mean i'm also
one of those people who's been driving
this for the last 60 years pretty much
um and not quite
and uh
and i've also ridden down it and i've
noticed it's got it's actually a little
bit narrower now because of the
undergrowth and somebody has commented
on that
um
and
it's quite but it is a little bit
narrower because of the undergrowth
on each side it was a little bit wider
before
and
i drove it today just to see what it was
like again um
and in fact
coming from margate from
coffee corner
the actually the the worst bend
there
is in fact where the new road's been put
in
and that's actually the one part of it
where you do tend to drift over to the
other side and it's and there's no sight
it's in fact the new road has been the
worst part of it
um in my opinion as a driver um i
appreciate that others are not driving
but um uh i i assume we're all
reasonably happy with the fact that it
it's going to have a reduced limit
i take it we're all happy with that
councillor crow brown yeah i've actually
had several complaints uh including my
colleague to the left of me um regarding
that narrow stretch on the bend by the
farm
yes
and i don't think the result will be
removing that curb it'll be more more
road signs unfortunately
which seems ridiculous
it's actually as you go past the farm
and just around the corner that new bit
there is actually
um it took me by surprise because it it
yeah the camera's wrong as well it's a
little bit like the camber at um
down at um over in ramsgate going out
towards cliffs end um
but uh your suggestion for white lines
would
be on the center might
might help
okay are we happy to uh
go with the recommendation um
that the reduced speed limit be
installed as advertised but comment that
something should be done to
make it more visible with white lines
council of hearts
yeah and also if we can make the comment
as other people have here the
undergrowth is just
it's not i mean the council are
responsible for the first meter and
every you know the owner of the land is
responsible after that and i think that
needs to be addressed to make sure that
you're not clipping your mirrors you're
not trying to push people into the
hedges or the sides the other side and
to try and make sure that these things
are maintained to the highest standard
because i mean i don't even use that
road anymore i just refuse to because i
don't want to smack my mirrors and some
people just fly down that road as if
they own it and it's just
and i used it for years and years and
years it was the quick way to stairs
realistically and i've just given up now
because it's just not it's just not
suitable to use really
um counselors yeah i don't use it
anymore because i think it's a very
dangerous road but also there's been no
real enforcement of lorries going down
there illegally
so again it comes back to enforcement
uh with most of these things it comes
back to enforcement without that um it's
dead in the water
so we can do what we like to the road
but um uh but as i said uh
i think there are areas that could be
improved i i did have actually one
question and that was um
that i noticed that um
on one of the documents the client is in
fact mystery house
trading as boba's homes and i just
wondered who is actually paying
for any works done there
be very interested no i was going to ask
the question of an officer but i forgot
that the officers aren't here
um
so i will ask that question because um
after all
the road has been there a long time and
it's only because there is no increased
traffic because of the development
that this becomes a major problem or
rather a more serious problem and
therefore it is interesting to know
who is actually footing the bill for any
works that have to be done because of
the development
and i'm assuming
it's the developer
but that may be a wrong assumption so i
will raise that question
it should be
it's not always um
so i would like to raise that question
but uh
we do have at least some comments on
this
um
and uh the recommendation is the reduced
speed limit being installed and our
comments are that we would suggest
addressing the
the undergrowth at each side
and possibly
making
a white line in center any other
comments
council scoby yes possibly some traffic
calming as well
because uh
cars do hurtle along there and if if if
you're going to have a 30 mile per speed
speed limit you need some way of
reducing or encouraging people to to
reduce that speed
is that
you just all you're doing is just
damaging your suspension and that's
really making your car work harder and
it doesn't it's not environmentally
when it comes to safety sure it would be
better to request that the the curb is
actually moved over
so there is more room because people
come so fast off that
that
wider stretch and there isn't room for
two vehicles
i've come around that corner
and there's been a small flatbed truck
and suddenly my portion of the road has
halved and i've gone had to go up on the
curb and i noticed the kerb is flattened
on the other side with tire tracks
i mean it is you know a fatality that
could occur definitely
and surely moving the curb i mean it's a
shocking example of uh modern road
constructions by developers who don't
actually think the whole thing through
they only had to be another even 30
centimeters over and you'd have more
room
it's a busy busy road
thank you we have several comments here
are we happy to put all of them forward
in which case i need a proposal for this
council
derrick crowe brown councillor scobies
is second
are members happy to put forward the
suggestions that we've discussed
great thank you very much
agenda item 8 is a briefing note on the
traffic management act
which you've all received
and
this is also for information are there
any questions or comments on this
nope
are we happy to note
the information
then we finally go on to agenda item
nine which is the briefing topics that
are requested on behalf of
various
others here
and those are
have various things here including the
budget for
the potholes
which you'll see
i
i requested um
the rules on
um road works and road closures because
stagecoach frequently say that they are
not informed
by third parties who are the
works promoters
who when they finish early do not
always
uh inform others such as stagecoach
that the road is now clear
so the diversion of the of the bus
continues even though everybody knows
the road is open
uh and these are things that they're
supposed to do but um
i think it's it's
i have asked for um i have asked for
kcc2
highways to um
emphasize
that they should be doing this once they
if they finish early and open them
and the road can be opened again because
it's not happening it's certainly not
happening in broad stairs always
and i said i assume it's not happening
elsewhere and um and i think there was
another one here about dropped curbs was
that f um for
councillor cornford
yes thank you chair um we have a lot of
older residents in westgate and we also
have a lot of drop curbs but they are
not fit for purpose they were built many
years ago
and with the increase of mobility
scooters there's a lot of discomfort
and in
instability
and it
it seems sensible with this huge push
for active travel for both mobility
scooters for just walkers and for
young families and push chairs to be
able to cross the road safely and easily
by using drop curbs
and if we were to go the whole hog then
a
dog bones to prevent vehicles parking
across this pedestrian access for active
travelers those on foot pedestrians the
the um
those are not no longer enforceable
and that is the problem they they are
still put into
um
onto pavement or other onto the the
roadside
but they're not actually enforceable
but but if if somebody requests them
they they do occasionally agree to to
put them there
it's it's more
an extra please don't park here
but um but unfortunately they cannot
force them
okay
but the condition of the the drop curves
could be improved because again it's
about improving the existing
infrastructure as councilor hart was
saying earlier about the cycle pathways
we've got them
you know if we don't have to reinvent
the wheel we just have to improve them
yeah
i think that probably comes back to
your kcc councillors
should be
notified and bring that up because there
is no there is no budget so it's a small
works that may be done from time to time
um okay
i think that's for council right and
council crow brown again
counts okay
thank you chair um i did also but if we
could again there's no offices available
but um if we could look into this i was
looking at the uh
item of uh scheduled road repairs and so
on and the budget for pothole repairs
that's been released within that and i
remember talking to paul valley last
year about the sum of money there to do
that but my query is that there doesn't
seem to be any policy
with regard to sort of maintenance
apollos they rely entirely on
members of our members or the general
public through the portal to report the
pothole which is fine and generally
speaking i found that they are fairly
good at coming out and depending upon
what it is how dangerous themselves not
a problem with that but
it all seems to be done by contractors
which again is fine but what i'm finding
in question is that you report a pothole
through the portal they'll come to do it
there's one sort of 10 meters away and
when you suggest they may like to do
that while they're
on on the site i'm sorry it's not on our
list and it gets done you report it
again on the port they come out two
weeks later and
is it not possible to get some sort of
conformity whereby once a pot that was
reported in that area whether or not
they could just
go up and down the road a little bit and
just fill in the minor ones before they
come major ones
thank you thank you
councillor lewis
yeah um i share your frustration it has
been raised
at camp kent county council and i wasn't
satisfied with the answer
so
put it politely don't hold your breath
i remember actually uh possibly not this
in the last year but certainly before
there was talk that they would
uh make sure that they did um
those in the vicinity if there was
something there that also needed doing
they would do it and i can remember that
about two years ago that that was
actually mentioned and
that they would do so so i think it's
fallen by the wayside um
i guess i'll be on behalf of
to to the defense of the county council
here
their budget
for highways as councilman lewis knows
better than i
is
it's a fraction of the
uh budget for
um highways what what was highways
england
and
yes
the cutback this year is nine million
pounds
from the
blitz budget
so if it's bad now it's gonna get worse
i'm sure he's faulty follow me to uh
set the truck
[Music]
we gully something you know they'll come
out and do one there's three more up the
road that are blocked although they've
been reported
two days
uh
afterwards then they'll come back again
it just seems like
there's no maintenance schedule at all
it's just
done on reports of the public or all
members yeah i mean kent county council
and logic doesn't always go hand in hand
and
i just you're on the transport
yeah
i will entrust that to you to bring up
and um
i will try but uh
say don't hold your breath i mean the
point is that
when you go out to contractors you by
definition are handing over
responsibility from the
kent county council to the contractors
so if you're if you haven't got direct
control of what's going on
you're in trouble that's why
you know most things are done better
in-house than contracting out
and that's my political speech
thank you
council right
thank you um i'm not sure which universe
it was whether it was county or district
but i seem to remember some time ago
it was mentioned that some it would be
maybe possible to put cameras onto the
dust carts so that as they go along they
can pick up the potholes
as they go
i'm not sure was that was that
county or was that district
it was i know it was mentioned somewhere
i mean that would be a really good idea
because it would keep it would keep
a very accurate
log of where the potholes are and where
the ones the small ones that could be
done quickly could be done
um i think uh money is the major problem
here um but certainly
uh that can be mentioned as as a comment
on the briefing that we've got here
and i'm quite happy to bring that
forward if members are agreed
councillor heart
thank you i must admit i it's not paul
vellick's fault and i will ring him up
um but i i think it's disgraceful that
he's
not here it's not his fault i understand
that but maybe the cabinet member should
turn up instead um because realistically
somebody should be here because
if we do have an issue you know i can go
to port i know there's a couple of
gullies that need emptying um and i was
going to talk to him tonight about it
because it's easy and it's personal and
i think that if the cabinet member wants
to stop his staff coming here then maybe
the cabinet member should get off his
backside and come here
because realistically it's disgraceful
and paul valak is a very good chat he
works very hard for this area absolutely
and we're very very lucky to have him
and and i think that he's been a
being
having a disservice to him by not
turning up and i think he will feel that
himself and i think that if the cabinet
member feels that that should be done
then he should turn up himself
and actually face us because you can't
have this sort of meeting without a kcc
representative
yeah it is very difficult i was not
aware that nobody was turning up i
thought somebody would be turning up on
um
turning up online but
it it turns out that they're not even
doing that yeah i i just i think it's a
sad state of affairs and we're here to
try and do the best for everybody else
if we've got minor matters it's much
easier to talk to paul at one of these
meetings rather than have a discussion
over the phone or try and meet him in a
coffee shop or whatever and i i just
think it's a great show yeah i think
we're all all agreed on that
uh council lewis
i think it might be useful if we're
gonna raise it
at county level can you clarify what the
remit of a
joint transport board is and anywhere in
those
um
constitution
does it mention
whether
we should have
officers here because
the problem i've got if i ask a question
at full council
why
are why is the cabinet member
refusing to allow the officers to come
here
he might just turn around so there's no
obligation on it so i think we need to
know
the constitution of the joint transport
board and whether it
gets covered in that i don't know if
that's possible
i don't have the terms of reference to
hand and so i don't think it's directly
mentioned in there however
the terms of reference say what we are
able to do
and
that it implies a certain amount of
communication
with
another party because after all if we're
making comments
it would be helpful if we if we're
having a report it would be helpful if
somebody is here to present it that is
what happens at council meetings
somebody who has written the report
usually presents it um but i will get
back with you with the full is
it possible that the members of the of
this committee
um you could email yes um around robin
of the constitution where it's um
applicable
or if it's not
because i i don't want to go to full
council and cause a stir and then the
cabinet members say just turns around
and say
don't have to we will send uh to every
member of this committee
uh the terms of reference i've got them
somewhere on mine but
to do it now is going to be a little bit
pointless
can i just just say that we do as as
chair and and vice chair chair and
officers who have a pre-meet now we
always have a pre-meet here face to face
but but through the friendship pendant
we had
a virtual one all members so and paul
would be there and pause but we have had
the last meeting with paul there so we
have had the choice of being able to
speak with paul directly and i think if
paul if they if they can't be here we
need to have all members virtually
either a pre-meet and then carry on here
or
the meeting be virtual
you see the trouble with that is we
can't have it live streamed for the
public so but we could have a pre-meet
with us all
virtual i should say so at least you get
the opportunity until paul and other
officers can could be with us
i don't know
we have discussed that and i think
that's something we need to raise again
the pre-meet
i was going to say members that for a
committee to be effective it definitely
does need technical input and for that
technical input to come in the officers
have to be in attendance and it's even
if it's not written in the terms of
reference it's by implication
which is what i think is is the case in
fact uh from what
um what i can remember of them
counselor
scoby thank you as a former chair and uh
vice chair of this uh austere body
um
for many years i have found this one of
the more useful uh
committees
of thanat district council and kent
county councils
um
however over the last few meetings i
have like a real become frustrated it's
four meetings a year
it's
not a big ask and not a uh you know
the meetings don't tend to go on for
hours and hours and hours you know we've
had somewhere they've been 20 minutes if
an officer can't turn up for a short
period of time it's it's a pretty poor
thing thank you
thank you um i
as i said we will send round the terms
of reference
and comments for
this agenda item as well as the others
actually for this one it is we've had
comments uh
have you got those all down
are there any more comments on
the final agenda item
no
are we happy to uh approve the comments
that have come
um plus a few others
uh and put them forward
probably to quite a few people now
okay thank you very much and that
uh ladies and gentlemen is the end of
the meeting
so thank you very much for your comments
and your input
um i'm sorry that it has been very
disappointing for you that we have not
had any input from officers
but i think we have to make our our
opinions known
and
i feel that this is
if it carries on like this it will be
it will almost be insulting to the
public
who after all
have value in attending these meetings
and hearing
uh explanations for why things aren't as
they would like or maybe
could not couldn't be like as they
wanted so
i think it's quite useful
that we see what happens when you don't
have office